welcome back the road to the bowl is
underway the SRS Distribution Las Vegas
Bowl who are sponsoring this segment is
taking place on December 17th at
Allegiant stadium and here tell us more
is John cicente the executive director
of ESPN events in Las Vegas Paul it's
great to see you man everybody good to
see you it's been a while it's been a
year it's been a year it's been a year
okay who who can we see playing in the
bowl this year well I think as of today
we're down to probably three teams
realistically on each side on the Pac-12
side I think we're down to Oregon UCLA
or Oregon State wow big teams okay yep
so so all all really good brands all
really good traveling teams on the SEC
side and this is an SEC Pac-12 matchup
this year we're the only Pac-12 SEC
matchup in the entire country but
realistically we're probably down to
about three which is Ole Miss
Mississippi State and maybe LSU
legendary schools this game is going to
be big it's big every year but this year
is going to be huge and you brought this
is the actual trophy that the teams are
playing for this is such a cool thing it
is and you're not allowed to touch it
it's a little fragile but this is our
baby we wanted to have a trophy I think
we have one of the more unique trophies
in in all of bowl season we wanted
something unique that said Las Vegas
right so the base of it is the is the
shape of the welcome the Las Vegas sign
uh the archways or the the archways
going towards downtown Las Vegas the
gold because we have such a gold mining
uh industry here in Northern Nevada but
then our our ball is uh an Elvis
inspired uh one of his last shows at the
Old Las Vegas Hilton he wore this uh big
eagle rhinestone white cape and it was I
see that the football right there yep
yep and then named after after the Bulls
founder and former CEO of the convention
business Authority Rossi rauencotter and
so we're proud of this one this one gets
a lot of attention I'm doing everything
in my power not to try to pick it up
because it's very heavy it's a heavy
it's a heavy trophy I'll tell you every
year when we present it to the winning
coach they were holding it for a picture
and then one of us has to let it go and
you hear the coach every year
and this is shot not just a game it's a
huge ball game but it's a week of events
leading up to it and you also have a
bunch of Charity tie-ins let's talk
about some of the charity events that
you have going on that week so it starts
off this Sunday which which is selection
Sunday uh which is our first event
um but we we have 21 events during the
course of a of a of a six day we're
watching last year's highlights yeah
Wisconsin ASU last year
um but but our two actually a three
charity uh um outings while the teams
are here is we're going to Opportunity
Village with the teams uh to spend a day
uh at Opportunity Village with the
clients we're doing uh the goody two
shoes Foundation Shoe Drive where we're
outfitting 600 kids with shoes and socks
and toys for Christmas uh goody two
shoes is a great partner of ours and
then we're going over to uh the Charity
Hospital over at Dignity Health St Rose
to spend a day with the cheerleaders and
and mascots and and a couple players uh
at the at the Children's Hospital so the
game is so big for our city with the
fact that you guys give back to Las
Vegas is very special and well I was
gonna say and our final event is our one
Vegas event which is the night before
the game last year we distributed 150
000 back to local charitable routes
through uh through our one Vegas event
which is celebrating the sports and
entertainment industry in Las Vegas and
recap in the year that was I gotta wrap
it up here John you're gonna be joining
us for a couple weeks leading up to the
games two more times
I'm going to hold this thing next time
dude you can do it it is so dude it's so
heavy workout every day
listening is
this is so happy Jillian I'm the champ
we'll send it over to you